it's mark griffin's nephew against the
uh artist formerly known as the third
overall pick in the 2018 draft
and to discuss that and more a man who
watches a ton of film because he's not
only a great a top-notch
talent evaluator in the world of
football he's also an nfl film senior
producer and the producer as well as
honor representative of nfl matchup on
espn he's none other than greg cosell
back here on the show how are you greg
rich great to be with you thanks what
are you seeing with darnold what is
going on with him what's your evaluation
of sam yeah i think i think darnold's at
the point right now where he is just
struggling to see things
and he's having a hard time executing
basic concepts
things at this point in his career he
should see
i also think he has a tendency to move
too much
when you're in the pocket and look we
know the game now a lot of people talk
about second reaction improvisational
plays
but those have to be more of a parachute
rich you can't just drop back and leave
the pocket you have to let
the design and structure of the play
play out and i think he's
he's perceiving pressure that's often
not there
and he moves too much now i will say
this one thing
when i evaluate a quarterback you have
to isolate the traits and attributes of
a quarterback
as opposed to just saying well there's
not a lot of talent around him
that's easy to say that there's not a
lot of talent around a player but you
have to isolate his traits and
attributes and characteristics and i
think right now darnold is a struggling
young quarterback
well i mean uh isolation uh for him
based on everybody else around him i
mean that's almost like solitary
confinement
in terms of uh evaluating greg i mean
but so so let me ask you this
uh where where where was you where were
you on the evaluation of that
quarterback group as a whole with him in
relation to mayfield and
and rosen and allen and and then lamar
jackson
for that draft where did you stand on
darnold coming in
correct well the concerns that he's
shown in the league were concerns i had
coming out i thought that he did tend to
move
he's also a guy that his lower body
mechanics he struggles with that he
doesn't always step to his throws
that may be just the way he throws the
ball josh allen's like that as well
you know josh allen's a little different
though the josh allen experience this
year you know it's been
it's been kind of fun um but uh but no
donald has some issues that need to be
cleaned up
and at some point if they don't get
cleaned up you end up being
kind of a maybe yes maybe no player
without consistency
we'll see where he goes in his career i
know that that adam gates has been an
easy
mark for a lot of people but at the end
of the day when you watch tape and the
tape does not lie
a quarterback must be able to execute
basic concepts
and donald's struggling with that right
now what about the concepts he's being
given
greg what about that you know
every every there's not a thousand
concepts
so ever there's there's basic concepts
that are on every playbook
um we can debate that at given times
about given play calls
those are always debatable but i think
when you see basic concepts that
everybody runs that are in every coach's
playbook
those have to be executed and you know
the interception for instance he threw
in the end zone to xavier rhodes last
week
week he just didn't see it at all you
know that he didn't read it he didn't
see it
you know that's something you have to
read and you have to see um
so and it's a route concept that's in
everybody's playbook it
was nothing where you could say oh oh my
god what's adam gase doing
so um greg you're an evaluator when i
sit in this chair i'm an opinionator
um so um i'd like you to evaluate the
opinion i came up with the other day
that the jets have officially broken sam
darnold whether it is
hiring a coach in midstream um and then
that coach coming in
and um with a general manager that gets
changed
midstream and the current general
manager trading away
their best defensive player on the eve
of the season then which
they're maybe second best defensive
player in the middle of the defense and
cj mosley ops out
they trade away their best defensive
player for draft choices
not people who can help darnold right
now they let robbie anderson go
that put it all together from management
all the way down to everything else that
sam
donald is officially broken by the jets
what do you say to that
yeah i don't know the answer to that
because i don't know what's in sam
darnold's head
um you know obviously you'd like to him
to be in a position where there's some
continuity
both with the coaching staff this is the
second year for gays i guess most people
just automatically assume
that this will be the last year i you
know i find that whole thing interesting
i never know where to go with that
because they won six of their last eight
games last year
right and and no one seemed to give gays
any credit for that because he's got
this
this persona uh that he's he's the
whipping boy for a lot of people which
i don't go into those kinds of things
but they did win six out of the eight
last year
obviously they're not very good this
year they've got a ton of injuries they
tried to upgrade their o-line
you know we'll see where it goes but but
right now
darnold is a struggling quarterback that
to me
some of that's independent of the
situation with the coaching staff and
and
and the general manager now that said
just uh before we move on
uh bechten looks like the real deal
right when you see that
yeah i have no doubt right i think i
think so they nailed that
i mean that guy's just a mountainous
human being and he's
he moves very very well and he seems to
have the nasty right he seems to have
the nasty words oh for sure i mean i
remember watching his tape at louisville
he he gets after people for sure
that he'll be a very good left tackle in
the league greg coachell here on the
rich eyes and show
now then uh i guess technically in your
backyard at nfl films
philadelphia pa what what do you see
about wentz what ails him what what i
guess
what's up with him essentially yeah he's
i think he's fighting it a little bit
right now he has some very very good
plays the touchdown he do to greg ward
last week was really high level mentally
uh and so you see those plays which we
know he's capable of
um but at times he's also a little lost
mentally with his recognition
what i call elimination and isolation
meaning eliminating what's not there and
isolating what is there
within the structure and timing of the
play
if you don't do that you end up playing
much too fast
physically and it might seem kind of
weird to say this but when you play fast
physically you end up being
slow mentally and you're tentative and
then you leave throws on the field that
are
there and when you add in the fact that
he's his poor ball placement he's
missing
some routine throws you've got a
struggling quarterback and
all you can do is fight through it you
know i i think it's like a baseball
player which
you know when you're in a hot streak you
could face the best pitcher on the
opposing team and the ball still looks
like a beach ball when you're in a slump
you could face the worst pitcher and the
ball looks like a bb
you know you just got to fight through
that he's fighting it right now a little
bit
his mechanics according to kurt warner
uh have been off for quite some time
is what he said for years is what kurt
mentioned last friday
when he came on the show what are you
seeing on film i would agree with that
um and i think that needs to continually
be worked on and i'm certainly not in
the building every day so i don't know
what they do
right but he tends to be an over strider
and when you over
stride one thing that happens
particularly when you don't have a
naturally compact delivery and he does
not have a naturally compact delivery so
when you over
stride you have to rush your upper body
to catch up
and he tends to rush his upper body to
catch up and that can lead to the ball
sailing and inaccuracy which we do see
at times
where do you stand on the concept of
sitting somebody for a week to just give
him a breather and see what you got in
the other kid
like jalen hurts what's your concept um
normally i'm not a believer in that um i
think you have to work through that i
you know i think that you i think you
run into more issues than less issues if
you do that
uh particularly in philadelphia
that you are an expert on as well you've
had a front row seat to that media
market i've been here for 41 years at
nfl film so i've
yes i have had a front row seat and my
good friend is ron jaworski and i know
you know him as well of course
i know all about that hey wasn't john
fasenda
a local anchor in philadelphia that the
sables said let's get him actually the
last person to work with john before he
passed away
come on really yep no
doubt what was it like yeah it was like
working with johnny well
i had worked with them prior to that as
well but you know he had gotten sick
this is probably 83 or 84
a long time ago and i we had to go to
his house because he wasn't doing real
well
but he could still narrate and he was
the nicest guy in the world i mean
those days are over where he had the one
guy he was the walter cronkite of
i know i'm aging myself here no rich but
he was the walter cronkite of
philadelphia news
absolutely uh greg cosell here uh on the
rich eisen show okay so now let's move
on to
uh what you saw on monday night football
my gosh
mahomes there's just there's no it
doesn't seem like
if you confuse him you should just like
pat yourself on the back
uh it's not as if he's not confusable
but you can confuse him it's just so
rare to do that and everything that andy
reid dials up
that if you fall down to the chiefs
which is more often than not
you better have an offense that can
potentially go point for point with them
and
it seemed like the ravens have trouble
with this they have yet to win
with lamar jackson at quarterback coming
back from a halftime deficit what do you
see about this offense and what's going
on with baltimore based on what we saw
well i think they're structured a
certain way rich the the reality is the
the offense is structured around lamar
jackson as a runner
and all the pass game works off of that
they don't really have
what we would view as as a true drop
back pass game in a strict sense
um so what happens is and i think steve
spagnolo did an unbelievable job now he
also
knows in his back pocket that his
offense is likely to put up 30-plus
points every week
and i think that that allows you to do
some things you might not otherwise do
but he pretty much said on third down
and other downs as well
you know what we're going to play press
man and we're going to blitz and
what that's going to do is it's going to
make your receivers have to win
one-on-one match-ups
and lamar you're going to have to make
precise ball placement throws
within structure and you know what if
you want to run around
that's okay maybe you'll make a big play
here and there because you're special
but you know what you're not going to
make enough of them to score 35 points
so that was the approach steve spagnola
took and it worked in that game so now
baltimore
i'm not saying every team will do that
because i'm not a blueprint guy you have
to do what fits your team
right every team can't do exactly the
same thing
but it'll be interesting to see if teams
feel that they can at least pressure a
little more
so you know where do you stand on the
subject that the reason why
the ravens offense is set up this way
is because lamar can't
do it vertically with his shoulder that
there is something
up with his skill set that he
can't do that i mean we heard that
coming out of louisville now he's old
for nine and games where he's trailing
at halftime it just
does seem that it's it's the way to to
beat the ravens i know you're not a
blueprint guy but if you get up on him
it's difficult for him to come back by
just
relying on him well to throw it i don't
i don't i'm not one of those
folks i do believe in his ability to
throw his arm is
terrific and i think he wants to be
great so it's not
it's not anything between the temples
but i'd love for your evaluation
greg well he's super competitive he's a
great kid i've been around him
he's as competitive as there is i think
he's an improving thrower
but i've always been a believer in one
thing and then i've watched tate for a
long time rich as you know
is that coaches tell you how they feel
about their players
by how they use them and this at this
moment
okay and and we we lose track because
lamar had a phenomenal year last year we
lose sight of the fact he's a third year
player
he's a young player they've built an
offense a certain way
because they feel that that maximizes
his strengths
and minimizes what they view as i don't
want to say weaknesses right
but things that he's not quite ready to
do
on a consistent week to week basis so
that's the way they built their offense
this is not me talking this is what they
do so
greg roman jim harbaugh james urban
their quarterback coach
this is what they do now because the
kid's so competitive and wants to be
great
yes he will improve but this is where
they are right now
greg cosell nfl film senior producer nfl
matchup on espn analyst right here a
couple more minutes left
with you sir uh the topic du jour in uh
new orleans or from new orleans
definitely is nationwide based on the
performance on monday night and the loss
in vegas and then
uh where there are tons of bubble
screens and air
uh targets in the air only five to seven
yards down the field
about drew brees the subject matter of
his arm strength and his age where do
you stand on this subject greg cosell
i think this has been true withdrew for
probably three four years i mean there
were a number of plays in that game
where they they actually
by design were looking to get the ball
down the field and the packers took it
away
and then therefore he comes down to um
uh
to something shorter for instance the
camaro 52-yard td reception
came on what was a called shot play they
had what we call a post-cross
combination
uh the ball was designed to go down the
field and that's where
drew looked but the packers took both
those routes away
with their coverage and therefore he
threw it to camara in the flat
drew does not have a big arm right now
they've played this way for a number of
years
look the way the game is structured now
you are always looking for explosive
pass plays
but i don't think drew is playing any
differently than he has in let's say
over the last year or two
um don't forget they gave up a lot of
points uh and they also scored a lot of
points you know so drew was 29 for 36
and they scored 30 points offensively
uh i think in most cases you would
probably take that
and wouldn't and and if they if their
defense had played better and by the way
their defense is really struggling
if they had won the game 30 to 24
because their defense had played better
would we be having this conversation
probably not
no not at all winning is the ultimate
deodorant as a matter of fact we had
cameras
i think the tape tells you right i think
he has and i think he's playing
kind of the way he's played for the last
year two years
now i mean we actually have michael
thomas who catches a lot of shorts
absolutely
and is very good run after catch we had
cameron jordan on the other day i said
how do you fix what's going on with the
penalties and everything he said win
that's what he said he said winning and
obviously that's the ultimate deodorant
and that's i guess the way i want to
finish up this segment with you greg
cosell
this has been a quarterback driven
segment so far the best defense you've
seen on film through three weeks where
again no preseason we've seen a ton of
points points are up
in a significant way but the best
defense that you've seen
so far in the all 22 while you've been
doing your film work is is which defense
well and they have not played great
teams so people are going to say that
but i you know to me i look
at just how they play and what they do
and i'd say that's the steelers
i think the steelers are really good at
all three levels of their defense
um you know we've always talked about
someone like bill belichick
stylistically that he's about front
multiplicity and coverage consistency
because they play so much man
the steelers to me are the reverse their
their fronts are very consistent they
basically rush
four when they get to their nickel and
dime but their coverage is they do
so much in the secondary with disguise
late movement
it's really muddy the looks for the
quarterback so to me the steelers are a
really really good defense now obviously
they don't play this week it would have
been a very interesting game against
tennessee
but the steelers defense to me they're a
fun watch
and then which which defense of a of a
of a
of a team that has super bowl
aspirations has concerned you the most
that you've seattle huh why you yeah you
just spit that one right out what is it
yeah because i you know hey i picked
russell wilson to be the league mvp in
august and i think uh
you know so far so good we've only
played three weeks but you know
you got to pat yourself on the back rich
when you can right so um
i think their defense has significant
concerns on the back end
uh they've lost jamal adams probably for
a week or so with a muscle injury
um but their defense is struggling on
the back end and
and they just give up too many explosive
plays and that's the killer in this
league so would you say the most
complete team could be green bay with
the way that aaron rodgers is playing
and the way that the green bay defense
appears to be showing up um
what do you think about that in terms of
the most complete team in the league
yes sir i would probably have to say
right now that would be kansas city with
the way spags is putting together that
defense
and we know that they can score so i
probably have to look there but green
bay is playing very well
um i i love what they're doing
offensively with matt leflore
there's a lot more play action play
action boot misdirection
things that cause problems for defenses
tactically and schematically
and rogers is throwing the ball
beautifully so
yeah they're they're a really good team
greg um
and you're a great uh analyst love the
segments
as always when you come on um we'll be
checking you out on nfl
matchup on espn this coming up weekend
and let's uh let's keep uh conversing
thanks for the call
i appreciate it rich thanks so much you
guys greg cosell nfl film senior
producer
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here